joining us uh from the worldwide leader
in sports uh with um a free agency in
full bloom waiting
for deshaun watson's decision todd
mcshea back here on the rich eisen show
happy st patrick's day to you sir it
feels like the wolverines have been down
since tip off it has been winning two i
got to win
winning two games in the bracket what's
going on man what do you got to get your
guys in line okay man uh i'll be i'll
get right on that but here's the thing
uh i'm i'm laser lock focused on this
interview uh more than any other in the
show because it's half time so
you know perfectly timed todd perfectly
timed so who do you have winning at all
what's your bracket look like i went
with kentucky i wanted to pick uh
some someone out of the uh out of the
one seat okay my bracket's always a mess
i paid 30 seconds attention to it i'm
back to some guard
from from virginia tech right now so
that's that's your lane that's your lane
okay so uh looking at your 3.0 mock
draft uh aiden hutchinson i think based
on the free agency moves made by
jacksonville they're basically tipping
their hands that they're going to go
with uh aiden hutchinson first overall
correct yeah that that's what it seems
to be and again
cam robinson they franchise tag him it's
just one year they could if they went
with evan neal from alabama or icky aqua
new from north carolina state they could
move parts around on their offensive
line and make it work and certainly you
know protect the investment but it just
it kind of to me signals
especially with the free agency moves
that they've made you know heavily on
the on the offensive side it just
signals that
they they fell in love with aiden
hutchinson in the interview process how
could you not they you know they see a
player that can come in and provide joey
bosa like production and and hopefully
he's he's able to stay healthy and and
and be basically the player and not just
the the player but the leader and kind
of the heartbeat of the defense like he
was at michigan so why kyle hamilton
second why do you think the lions will
go in the direction of the extremely
talented safety i don't know struggle
with this i mean you're the lions right
you need a quarterback but there's no
quarterback you feel comfortable
drafting number two right is my mindset
on it
unlike the other teams behind you like
the texans and the jets maybe to a
lesser degree and the giants
you know all these people really if you
look from from three to seven those are
teams that need offensive linemen and so
they're they're in position for equanu
and neil as i mentioned but the lions
don't have that big of a need at the
offensive line spot so you know penne
seoul obviously last year they brought
in that offensive tackle so i just think
kyle hamilton to me is one of the
i would say six impact elite players in
this draft and i know it's at the safety
position and i know he ran he didn't run
you know in the four fours like people
were hoping for but he plays like a 4-4
defensive back and he's like a
pterodactyl out there
and just from a quarterback perspective
he is such a pain in the ass to throw
around because he's got the best
reaction skills i think of any defense
back in this in this draft you would
just study him on tape and i just
constantly rewinding until my thumb gets
sore to see where the ball is going out
and then when when has the corner
recognized and broken on the ball and he
consistently is as fast as anyone in
this class and then he's at the 6-4
frame with the long arms and and he's a
playmaker when the ball's in the air i
mean just just check out the highlight
reel two interceptions that he had
against florida state and you get a real
sense of what his true range is not not
necessarily indicated by that 40-yard
dasher you ran who are the other impact
players that you were referring to you
said that hamilton's one of six yeah i
think aiden hutchinson kyle hamilton i
mentioned the two offensive linemen and
equanu and neil right
i think you've thrown the mix garrett
wilson to me is the number one receiver
in this class out of ohio state
then i also would have two defensive
ends
in trayvon walker from georgia
and
kayvon thibodeaux from oregon if i know
what i'm getting out of out of thibodeau
and we can get to that later but then
the other the other player i throw in
the mix i guess it would probably be
seven that would be sauce gardener from
cincinnati the cornerback yeah when i i
i saw him in person and i saw him and
i'm like oh my god what a what a
tall kid
on an island right six three he's got
what what was it 33-inch arms i think
right
he's he's nimble and quick
he didn't give up more than 13 yards in
a single game rich in a single game last
year i don't you can say well it's not
powerful like i don't care if
not a single game to give up more than
13 yards and and they play him on an
island in press man coverage it's not
like he was playing a bunch of different
coverages and zones and he was just all
right you take care of that third and
we'll we'll handle the rest
with the other 10 guys and so i just to
me he's so impressive and you can make
an argument if you're
if you're just dropped on this planet
today and you're studying derek
stingley's tape from 2019 is true
freshman year with that exceptional team
and the highly motivated you know derek
stingley at the time playing for for a
national championship
and the six interceptions that he had
again is a true freshman and you watch
that tape and compare it to what you
watched this past year 2021 of sauce
gardener
i i'm i'm cool if you say that you like
the 2019 stingray tape better because i
think it's pretty close to a top up
they're both top
you know it's pretty much
even in terms of what you saw on those
two tapes and they were both exceptional
the problem is the last two years you
had a liz frank injury with stingley and
i i can give you seven or eight things
off the top plays off the top of my head
where i'm saying what is he doing you
know like taking bad angles pursuing
angles just so he doesn't have to get in
the mix turning down tackles not being
aggressive and physical in coverage it
just it was not the same guy in 2020 and
2021 that we saw back in 2019 and that
that's why there's concern and that's
why one of the five most gifted players
in this class is probably going to fall
beyond seven or eight in this strap i've
heard teams say it might be kind of
closer to the middle of the first round
todd mcshea here on the rich eisen show
let's unpack uh thibodeau a little bit
because you know i'm i'm on the air live
at the combine sitting next to daniel
jeremiah and you know we're expecting
him to work out after running his 40
because that's what he
said at his podium when he spoke to the
media that's what we had heard he told
teams he was going to do
and then you know it's now time after
running his 40 in a terrific 40. um we
see him put his backpack on his shoulder
and i'm kind of you know i get in the
air my producer i'm like what's what's
up with this
and
for somebody who's
went into the combine with questions
about his tape and his motor and things
of that nature
this is this is not a very good way to
place yourself out there in front of the
scouts but then the eye in the sky
doesn't lie when his motor's on so where
do you stand
on on this intriguing kid
yeah i i think he hit on it
if aiden hutchinson
didn't work out or jermaine johnson who
averaged 61 plays last year for florida
state and was playing his tail off in
the fourth quarter of games they were
losing and and he really didn't have
much to play for from a team perspective
or trayvon walker you know some of these
other edge guys that you see on tape
down in and down out that they are
giving everything that their body has to
give
if one of those guys didn't work out and
pulled that stunt because it was it was
i mean why why are you telling everyone
why are you going on interviews why is a
lot of personnel people scratching their
head because we expected to see
thibodeau work out and then you just
decide not to on really the biggest it's
the biggest stage in the pre-draft
process the nfl scouting combine
and how do you pull that off in front of
all the general managers and the
decision makers that are deciding your
fate and then even it's little stuff and
i'm not it's not the reason that the
problem but it's just kind of an
indicators to what you see on tape
you're looking to see something
different in the interviews you're
looking to see
words being backed up by action
and so
when you see a play here and there on
tape you say well you know he came back
and played he could have opted out and
this and that and maybe you can help
make excuses for it but now he's making
it easier like the comment he made about
clowney 2.0 pick any other guy in the
league man pick any other and again it's
not that big of a deal but where's the
advice coming from and and and where is
like the lack of understanding of the
process if you're in like
we the only thing we talked about with
debbie and crony is he's the number one
player in that draft he's the best
talent in that draft
but the road the motor runs hot and cold
and we're not sure what we're gonna get
and that's you know that was why some
teams were just not sure of them it's
the same exact narrative that you have
right now for thibodeau so it's been
it's been fascinating to watch listen i
pull for all of these guys he's a good
young man he really like i've talked to
people close to him like he's a good guy
i just want him to kind of pull it all
together because when you see the plays
that stand out you're like my goodness
he's got a chance to be special if he
just
focuses on what he needs to focus on
well i mean but you know the way this
thing works you know uh oregon pro day
uh once that thing hits i'm trying to
get the date right now
i know you wouldn't know that off the
top of your head but oregon pro day once
that one once they do that on on the
first of april there there will be no uh
april fools i mean i'm sure the kid when
he works out there it's gonna be scouts
will be like holy crap you've got a
ninth on your mock draft board going to
seattle would he be higher if if
if
that didn't happen at the combine that's
why i'm just trying to suss it all out
despite what you and i are saying let's
put it this way it didn't it just didn't
help him it was an opportunity to help
himself if he goes out there what do you
run it for i don't have it in front of
me a four he ran the four or fives
you know and so yeah like if he takes
that 40-yard dash that he had and goes
out and and does the explosive drills
and and just the movement on tape you
see it like he may not be the bendiest
guy
in in the in the class or you know going
back and comparing him to elite elite
pass rushers but he has he's explosive
and and he's sharp with his movements
and he's sudden and and he just he knows
how to to get through things he's got
such quick feet so to me he would have
gone out there put on a show and we
would have been talking about you know
what that's the player he is he was
playing in oregon the last couple of
years he could have he had an
opportunity to opt out he didn't maybe
the game tape was a little bit up and
down but he's dialed back in and this is
the guy that we're gonna get so it's not
that he's dropping because of the
no not working out it's just it's the
concern that you have with him in terms
of what you're going to consistently get
over the long haul i've got uh todd
mcshea here on the rich eisen show so
taking a look at your mock draft for the
quarterbacks let's hit the quarterbacks
a little bit here oh i uh before i send
you on to your good day um you've got um
pickett 18th to the saints and then
you've got the falcons trading back into
the first round to go grab matt corral
at 29. obviously desean watson's
decision would potentially change all
that you got malik willis 20th to the
steelers i'm with you man
the way i looked at the uh trubisky
signing is steelers are going to go get
this kid from liberty if he's still
sitting there 20th overall i mean that's
that's a fact in my mind and then full
disclosure i did this trubisky it was
the day after this mock draft came out
okay and trubisky signed and i still
i wouldn't do it differently i really
wouldn't if there's now i don't think
they're going to trade up and give away
other capital to in order to go get a
quarterback but if one falls in their
lap it actually would be a perfect
opportunity for for um for willis malik
willis who's coming out of two years at
liberty strongest arm in the class he
steps into the league he's one of the
three most dynamic athletes the
quarterback position right away but he's
not there mentally yet because it's just
two years starting like i said at
liberty after transferring from auburn
and even his own coach said hugh freeze
and and he had nothing but you know
glowing reviews of him and how great he
is as a person and teammates absolutely
love him and want to be around him and
fight with him and then he said he's the
most competent humble athlete i've ever
coached he also said
he doesn't know what he doesn't know yet
you know it's all kind of new to him at
the quarterback position so
he has developing to do and i'd love to
see him in a situation where he doesn't
get thrown in right away where he has
people around him who can develop him
because i'm telling you richard if this
guy gets the right situation and is
coached properly and has an organization
that gets behind him kind of like
baltimore has done with lamar jackson
like the bills did with josh allen even
what the eagles did this past year with
with jalen hurts
he's got an opportunity not only to be
the best quarterback in this class but
to be one of the you know best 15
quarterbacks in the league and that's
saying a heck of a lot so
i i love his upside but i'm scared to
death if he goes in the wrong spot
whether it's you know the coaching the
the organization around him the
supporting cast being thrown in too
early there's a there's a lot of things
there that are concerning but again his
upside is phenomenal last one for you it
usually takes as you hear the old axiom
four or five years to evaluate a draft
how do you evaluate baker mayfield right
now and what has happened with him
with the browns uh how
how are you sussing this out and if the
browns do move on from him is there
someone in the draft
and then the third part the question
huh
is where would mayfield look best do you
think
yeah i mean obviously
you know i had sam darnold ahead of him
i think it was that year so i
but i i liked him you know i liked him a
lot and he has he hasn't played to the
level i think i think his body type and
his play style
has affected him and it's almost you
know you look i'm not saying he's not
that matt corral is baker mayfield but
it's a little bit of that like
aggressive moving around don't have the
body
you're hoping that he can hold up but
it's it's taken a toll on him
and i think some of the like high energy
you know not rah-rah but just his his
demeanor when things aren't going well
people you know grown grown men don't
want to hear from you you know and and
the way you are and like early on i
think people in the organization bought
into it and and appreciated that about
them it seemed to have kind of
taken its course and worn worn some
individuals down inside that
organization so we'll see but it clearly
he's not going to be a cleveland brown
from everything i'm being told uh moving
forward
and you know who who who still needs a
quarterback we talked about the colts is
one the panthers is another one new
orleans is new orleans getting to sean
watson really seems to have come down to
four teams but i'm starting to hear more
whispers and kind of you know
indications that new orleans is the
place that desean wants to go so that's
the biggest domino that has to fall in
all of this with the quarterbacks but
certainly the the cultures and
organization that you would look at and
the carolina panthers are everyone's
kind of in this holding pattern you know
what does desean do you got four
organizations who throw in the browns
and the falcons and what does deshawn do
and then if it's not desean jimmy
garoppolo and baker mayfield then become
available
and it'd be a trait so it's this has
been one of the most fun interesting and
crazy you know
pre-free agency periods and free agency
periods and mostly because of the the
trades that we've seen and the decisions
obviously with tom brady and aaron
rodgers to go back to their respective
teams well just throwing it out there
real quick is there somebody that would
fit the browns i mean if you're saying
and you're hearing that it does seem
like the writing's on the wall that
mayfield's gone no matter what and your
colleague
shefter and our friend shefter is
reporting out uh that the browns have
already been told they're out
so oh really yeah uh-huh what happens
when i watch virginia tech guards for
the afternoon that's what happens
um
so you're asking me is that like with
the brown sitting there at 13 like could
they possibly be players in this draft i
mean that's that's around where you
expect these quarterbacks to go you know
seattle would probably be the earliest
in my opinion that the team would take a
quarterback at number nine the browns
would be 13 and we know the two names
it's kenny pickett from pittsburgh and i
know the hand spam thing isn't a big
deal it's not like it doesn't define a
player but if you're playing in
cleveland and and rain and the and wins
are affecting a quarterback and everyone
says well he played in pittsburgh yeah
but in the second half against north
carolina he struggled in the rain on the
wednesday practice of the senior bully
struggled mightily in the rain and no
quarterback was affected more out of the
six quarterbacks there i guess i worry
about him in that division and where you
have to play i'd much rather see him
like in the nfc south for example uh
where you know you're you're covered for
the vast majority of the season by domes
and warm weather stadiums todd mcshape
look for more of my calls you're the man
thanks for taking this one appreciate it
you got it rich oh it's fun you gotta
make [ __ ] at mcshay 13 on twitter i
follow him you should too hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here